6 15 on your tuesday morning time to  gift somebody a good day 8 news now  partnering with albertsons to brighten  people's days like this  i met vaughn over at one of the  albertsons in henderson he told me he's  a big fan of that particular store it's  a good store i mean the produce is great  everything is easy to find and it's a  close proximity to my house what he  didn't know was he was about to get a  big surprise we're gonna gift you  a good day and we're paying for your  groceries today vaughn welcome  thank you thank you wow  thank you all this has been that's a  great experience each and every time i  come here thanks a lot  there you go great great time surprising  vaughn getting to know him thanks again  to the folks at albertsons and everybody  involved with  all of us gifting good days it's such a  good feeling we have a great team here  at the station that goes out and sets  all these up for they're magnificent yes  they are